[Music]
you didn't think this was the end of the
story did you
we're all buzzing to know more about
descendents three and over the past few
months the cast dropped plenty of hints
about the movie stay tuned to find out
when the movie could get released if
you're new here make sure to subscribe
to the things and give our video a big
thumbs up now let's check out what we
know about descendants 3 so far the cast
so let's go ahead and solve the first
mystery who will actually be in the cast
for descendents 3 the Internet Movie
Database has kept everything very hidden
as none of the original casts were
actually announced on the movie just yet
but we have a feeling that will change
very soon of course we'll probably still
see the main for villains back in the
story since both previous movies have
been about them so that means Duff
Cameron will still play mal Cameron
Boyce will be Carlos booboo Stewart is
Jay and Sophia Carson is Evie but there
will most likely be other actors that
will appear again in the movie don't
forget we also saw uma in the end of
descendants 2 if you've watched the
bloopers and deleted scenes you probably
know that Disney was also one of the
characters that got to the iconic
descendants ending Harry hook even got
to do his part although it was uma who
was chosen for the actual release so
there's a good chance we'll be seeing
her in descendants 2 we also have a
feeling Mitchel hope will return as Ben
since Ben and mal story is only just
beginning
as of February 2018 most of the actors
have a clear schedule with no other
projects confirmed apart from China and
McClain who is playing Jennifer Pierce
in black lighting even deaf Cameron's
movie dumpling is now in post-production
meaning her schedule is free either this
is a huge coincidence or it's a
confirmed fact that descendants three
are coming faster than expected we can't
wait to get more news about the cast and
see who else might be coming to join
them so make sure to let us know your
ideal cast for the third movie the story
so what could descendants 3 possibly be
about if you saw any of our other
descendants videos you know we shared a
lot of theories that were made by some
of the biggest fans of the movies we
even introduced fan fictions and
strategize on what could and what
couldn't potentially happen for the next
series but just as a reminder
here's where dissonance 2 left off now
an umma had a pretty epic battle that
ended with Mao and been reunited in a
sweet moment but in the final scene we
saw her here asking the iconic
descendants question that confirms the
third movie was going to happen we also
saw dizzy accepting an offer to attend
auradon prep and fairy godmother got
Mao's spell book so where does that
leave us well Cameron Boyce has his own
idea for the third movie
he told team vote that his dream is for
a barrier to come down on the aisle that
lets the parents come to our Adan and we
could witness an epic duel between the
kids and the parents wouldn't that be
awesome we have a feeling that would be
one of the most iconic final scenes ever
but since we don't really want
descendants to end after the third movie
we feel like they should save this idea
for later Kenny Ortega admitted they're
not thinking about the plot of the third
movie as of yet as they wanted to see
how the fans respond so there's a good
chance people will see exactly what they
want to see that definitely means there
will be more romances spats battle songs
solos and most importantly we'll
probably see the dreamy harry hook again
there's nothing we'd want more than a
dreamy do ads and another chance for Mao
to do her solo since one of the deleted
scenes from dissonance 2 involves now
singing if only guys we still can't
believe this movie is actually coming
we're so excited
the release date so when is it actually
coming on the 13th of February 2018
Disney posted an Instagram photo saying
they're having a big announcement and
diehard descendants fans were absolutely
floored when they noticed that the small
glimpse at the back of the announcement
looks strangely like The Descendants
franchise logo on February 12th dove
Cameron tweeted she wishes she could
tell us what she's filming because
everyone would flip out by the time
you're watching this Disney will
probably announce descendants 3 as the
official movie but since we don't know
what the release date will be we can
always speculate after all the first
movie premiered on July 31st 2015 and
the second movie was released on July
21st two years later if the production
team is following this schedule we could
expect dissonance 3 to hit the big
screens in july 2019
but if duff Cameron's tweet means she
was actually filming the
since three it could possibly mean that
the team is getting ready to release the
movie in late 2018 don't forget that
this movie also requires plenty of
special effects so it makes sense that
it took two years for the second movie
to be released but anyways were super
excited fans are also predicting we'll
be seeing the trailer for the movie
about three to four months before the
release since that's when we saw the
trailer for descendants too and while
this might be a long wait we can
guarantee it'll be totally worth it
after all the first two movies didn't
disappoint and we're pretty sure the
third one will get us even more excited
let's just hope we're getting that
iconic scene at the end because to be
completely honest we definitely don't
want the descendants movies to finish so
come on share your own predictions with
us we want to know all about your
favorite cast your dream stories and of
course when you think the actual movie
is going to come out comment below and
let's discuss descendants three that's
it for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things and hit that
like button for more videos like this
one see you next time
[Music]